[Música]
oi gente bom dia meu nome é renato
o aluno do 5º ano e hoje a minha
apresentação vai falar sobre uma coisa
que está presente na nossa vida todos os
dias como meninos e meninas de todas as
idades são afetados pela desigualdade de
gênero desde a infância e muitas vezes a
gente nem se dá conta quer ver quem
nunca falou ouviu coisas como essa
menina corre nenhum moleque
ou então nossa você qual é que nem uma
menininha
já pararam para pensar que correr é uma
atividade que não tem relação nenhuma
com o fato de uma criança ser menino ou
menina
isso é coisa de criança quando uma
criança nasce ela é automaticamente
colocada dentro de uma caixinha de
possibilidades automaticamente os
meninos vão ser tratados como super
heróis corajosos e destemidos enquanto
as meninas vão ser sempre princesas
frágeis e indefesas e não tem nenhum
problema e você é menina gostava de
brincar de boneca ou você é menino
gostava de jogar bola
o problema é quando uma criança não pode
brincar de alguma coisa porque ela é uma
menina e um menino
e sabe por que isso é um problema porque
esse tipo de limitação está ligado a uma
coisa muito maior do que poder ou não
poder jogar bola
acontece que essa mesma divisão entre as
coisas que são femininas e masculinas
acabou virando um problema para todo
mundo
esse problema tem nome o nome que vem
sendo bastante discutido ultimamente
você já deve ter ouvido falar sobre o
machismo o machismo é a idéia de que o
homem é sempre melhor do que a mulher
colocando um monte de regras de
comportamento responsabilidades que não
fazem sentido para os dois lados
é claro que muita coisa já mudou
principalmente quando a gente compara os
dias de hoje com o passado mas muita
coisa precisa mudar para acabarmos com
essa desigualdade é uma coisa que é bem
importante é a gente entender o que a
palavra feminismo significa feminismo é
nada mais nada menos do que acreditar
que todas as pessoas são iguais ou seja
igualdade nem melhores nem piores de
interesse
ao contrário do que muita gente pensa o
feminismo ao contrário do machismo
porque não coloca ninguém situação de
superioridade mas sim de equivalência
isso é bom pra todo mundo
mulheres e homens que têm habilidades e
dificuldades diversas e por que é tão
importante discutir essas coisas desde
cedo porque quando a gente entra numa
loja de brinquedos e encontra coisas
relacionadas à causa filhos de beleza na
seção de meninas e coisas relacionadas a
diversas profissões aventura e esportes
na seção de meninos
a gente tem um problemão para os dois
lados não tem nenhum problema em as
crianças brincarem de casinha o problema
é quando essa é a única possibilidade
para as meninas
ou então quando os meninos são proibidos
de brincar dessas coisas porque a
brincadeira de menina brincadeiras de
menina levantam aqui enquanto os pais
trocava a fralda dos filhos
então tá bom viu então qual é o problema
de um menino brincar de fazer o mesmo
outra coisa porque os fogões de coisas
de cozinha tem que ser todos cor-de-rosa
- não pode cozinhar aposta que todo
mundo aqui já ouviu falar do fogaça e
tem um outro lado também quantas vezes a
gente já ouviu falar das brincadeiras de
menino jogar futebol andar de skate com
essa porque mon quantas meninas aqui
gosta desse tipo de brincadeira viu eu
conheço várias que jogam videogame muito
melhor do que
moleque por aí muito melhor do que muito
moleque por aí
isso é um problema sabe por quê
por que a gente é criança e toda criança
pode brincar do que quiser porque quando
a gente crescer a gente vai poder ser o
que a gente quiser médicos engenheiros
advogados professoras donas-de-casa
donas-de-casa pais e mães iguais porque
quando a gente perceber que todas as
pessoas são livres para ser e fazer o
que elas quiserem independente de
qualquer coisa a gente viver num mundo
muito melhor e mais divertido
o lugar que respeitar as diferenças e
aprende com elas por isso pais não
transmitam idéias machistas para seus
filhos
então vamos fazer
então vamos alugar a diversidade e fazer
parte dessa corrente
então vamos construir juntos um futuro
melhor e mais justo para todas as
crianças
então que tal começar assim brincando a
esse aqui um desenho que eu fiz com a
minha mãe que será nossa idéia de como
seria a loja de brinquedos ideal para os
dias de hoje uma loja que não seja
dividida por sessão de menino exceção de
menina
muito obrigado